you said you knew a lot of toxic girls
or you've seen that situation toxic
relationships and I've seen like toxic
relationships with a woman is like the
aggressor or like the the toxic person
and did she change
um I don't know her well enough to know
that so I can't really speak on it but
um
yeah people some people change but you
know what it is again like
self-reflection is really hard to do
when you have to look inwards and look
at yourself on your own flaws a lot of
people would rather ignore that because
ignorance is bliss there's someone in
the chat said people only change when
the reality of their life convinces them
to make a change yeah 100 big big
situations happen or something that
would just so yeah yeah I feel like a
lot of people have to hit rock bottom
for them to realize okay I need to
change this I need to like that's true
yeah that is true one time I was dating
a guy that my dad didn't like and
um I said I said dad do people change
that was a couple years ago and he looks
at me and he says yes
they get worse over time
no
[Music]
[Laughter]
no because it would just get under your
skin more word as the time goes on if
you don't like something you're not
vocal about it from the beginning like
it's gonna how would you expect it's
gonna dwell on your mind yeah I feel
like
Alexa personal a person can only fix
themselves and for them to fix
themselves they have to make countless
mistakes in order for them to realize yo
whoa what am I doing that's it 100 I
agree with that and that includes sorry
sorry that includes going back to the
triggers you were talking about because
without those triggers how would you
know that you're ready for change or
you're ready to change you know okay I
think a lot of people can like
um based our like toxicity of like a bad
upbringing and stuff but you know what
you get to a certain age where you need
to be held accountable for like your
behaviors and stuff not necessarily you
can't blame it you can't blame it on
your your childhood and stuff because at
the end of the day like you can see
someone who's got like grown up with
like alcoholic parents actually somebody
I saw a post and it was like twins and
they grew up in a household with like
two alcoholic parents and one of them
became a complete alcoholic just like
his parents and the other one fixed his
whole life had a successful business and
stuff you know like if you you've been
given cards but it's just like it
depends what you want to do like you can
either learn from that and be like okay
I don't want to be like that I'm going
to make a change so I'm not that kind of
person or you can just be like Oh I'm
like that because my parents were like
that I'm like this because I grew up in
a bad environment
you think that's because of mindset it's
mindset so why did you say no the reason
why I said not necessarily was because
like she just said the first twin
decided to be more of an alcoholic and
the second Twin decided make a change of
his life and there are two different
people but still one person's doing the
same household but as you just said
mindset it depends on who you're around
with yes it is a decision but at the
same time
you can't do by yourself you need people
to help you 100 don't don't you get to
choose the people in your life yeah you
do by the same time over the age of
eight you guys have all come across
really but I'm pretty sure you guys are
walking across really bad people but you
didn't end up being like them you
chilled with them yeah but you're not
them right but at the same time you like
realize like I don't want to be like
this so you're not going to associate
yourself with people that again it's
like we start having having
um boundaries is that what you accept
into your life yeah 100 do I mean the
same way we don't have the same bodies
the same way we don't have the same
mindset no 100 a mindset is something
that you learn like over time yeah and
everyone's way of learning is different
at the same way school isn't for
everyone it's the same way the way you
take education differently yeah yeah so
I can't be a demo personally change
their lives but at the same time like
you can't sit there and blame everything
else for the way your life's turned out
because everyone has a sub story like
everyone goes through yeah but it
just it's like it's about how you it's
about how you deal with it you know if
you don't want to be in that situation
then you work towards getting yourself
out of that situation you know if you
sit there and you sulk and you're like
oh I'm in this situation and you don't
make no change like how do you expect to
grow how do you expect yeah exactly you
have to become the change and take
actions towards that change like
thinking and all of that is nothing with
that action you gotta continue
consistently execute it that's really
important
it is I have a question for you guys do
you think that people who constantly
label their exes as toxic are looking
for an excuse for the failed
relationship yes yes 100
yes I would say yes as well yeah
it gets to a point again like you need
to look inwards if all of your
relationships are toxic and the other
person was always the bad person
look again
I'm just thinking now actually that
going back into whether I'm toxic I just
realized that I've never been a toxic
one
you've never you've never I've never
I've always I'm a person I've been on
the sweet the sleeping do you feel like
okay wait I'm gonna um
where are you where are you were you
going through your ex's likes
were you
looking at who he followed
yes but but no that's not toxic that's
not toxic
one in the chat if that's toxic
that's just one person out of how many
people in the world
[Laughter]
[Music]
a lot of people my age not even my age I
meet a lot of girls that they say the
same thing obviously we spoke about the
whole of our dude covered already about
relationship that's different you're in
there for trust yeah but when you're
like dating you're getting to know a
person I think you should be curious to
see whether you can trust them or not
it's out of curiosity they don't do it
all the time how can you trust someone
by looking at their Instagram followers
no no but what'd you mean because you
said oh you checked the followers to see
if you can trust them but how is
checking the followers scene you can try
no but you're just curious to see what
type of goals he follows the sexualism
they're or not question is how long do
you have to be curious for
I mean
are you able to see what type of corner
guy watches
[Laughter]
to me it's just like I don't know it's
Instagram guys look that's what they do
yeah like it's general in general like
if it's a pretty girl like you're gonna
appreciate the beat you're gonna like
the photo like the same way it's like if
you see pretty girl on the street you're
gonna look I don't know about you but
like whenever I go over because
this is actually normal like
prostitution is normal escort is normal
it's normal prostitute do you know a lot
of prostitutes
from what I've seen on someone on social
media okay yes it's a norm I was like in
your school did you know any no no I
think it's definitely an account I think
it's definitely blown up in popularity
not that it's blown up in popularity but
it's become more normalized even though
it was like it's the oldest like way of
making money for a woman like in the
world yeah but like yeah I think it
makes money social media it's definitely
like blown up in popularity and it's
more like in your face like yeah and the
reason why it's normal is because no one
has any Marvels no more does not exist
no more with me it does I'm talking for
myself that it does I know about you
guys but most does not exist morals
don't
existence can I ask the question because
I actually heard you you're saying
you're saying for society yeah okay yeah
listen I want some advice here what
would you guys do not advice not for me
but for watching what would you guys do
if if um he was in the DMS off the goals
he was lacking and following
um well I think that's about it together
I think that's a bit different I mean to
be honest if you're not together you're
not together here's the absolute freedom
to do it again until you decide that you
guys are both exclusive or you're in a
room I know a lot of guys that will read
you know when you react with the love
heart eyes
what do we think about is that not DMs I
don't think that's really appropriate
yeah I don't think there's one whole
reaction I don't think it's appropriate
but like if you just like a photo like
obviously when you send that like the
heart eyes to the DM it's like basically
starting a conversation it's a really
revealing photo
sheesh that's even worse no yeah that is
well see you guys are contradicting
exactly what we've you was saying before
my question but my question is how do
you know that and that's what I'm saying
like
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait so I'm saying how do you know that
so if you know that information you're
probably going through his legs yeah
going through his following and you're
going so much wait wait wait wait wait
so my whole point is that if you know
all that information you're probably
toxic because you're probably all over
his
I'm not I'm not saying that it's okay
for him to do that yeah but my whole
point is like a lot of wait to wait my
whole point is a lot of times girls will
will talk about how toxic he is but it's
like how did you find out that
information you're toxic too because
you've probably had some trauma in the
past or something that happened in the
past that makes you want to do it in the
future so even if it's a good guy and
you go into a relationship you're not
going in in good faith and you're going
to through all his before he's even
done anything before you're even dating
no yeah
it depends on the length that girl is
going to doesn't make sense there's
different levels of it if it's like a
one-time thing cool maybe it's
constantly then you've got a lot of it
it's still my question how do you know
[Music]
because how does it make you feel when
you do that how is that but how does it
means you know like you're looking
for problems
if you're going through his likes I'm
agreement and the crazy thing is what
y'all do
y'all go through the likes you'll go
through the following and instead of
just ending it no you start a fight and
you don't break up with him so it's like
why did you even go through it to begin
with Victor
I've just not looked at it and just
lived your life because if you're
looking for something and you find it
what's gonna happen now okay so anybody
found it and that's what I say like I've
just found that the girls that do that
stuff they just want the drama and the
fight and to fight and then get back
together and not break up and it's like
you know if she really saw it and really
ended it that would be one thing but
they never do
[Music]
um
wanting the drama and wanting the fight
I don't think it's intentionally I want
to fight I want to find this drama it's
more of can I trust you can I trust you
that's trauma I think yeah I think it's
a bit of insecurity there because at the
end of the day like why would you get
into a relationship with someone you
don't trust yeah it doesn't make any
sense to me does he even like you with
like yeah if you're constantly if you're
in a relationship and you're constantly
trying to find out if he's doing
something you clearly don't trust him so
you shouldn't be with him you know
someone could break her trust after a
while yeah
yeah someone can break your trust over a
long time but if you don't trust someone
like and you're not willing to trust me
but you know you can trust someone then
and not not trusting them and that's
them breaking a trust that you thought
that you of course but I think a
relationship is the foundation of a
relationship is true
got a healthy relationship if you don't
trust you trust them yeah yeah yeah I
just think it's healthier like okay if
it comes to you fine yeah yeah but it's
like if you're out looking for problems
like you're toxic okay yeah you can't at
the end of the day ignorance as Bliss
yeah so like if something's going on
behind closed doors and you're not aware
of it and he's keeping it on the
download and like you don't know nothing
like it can't hurt you yeah and you
think that's okay no I don't think
if you find something suspicious and you
don't trust them and something does come
to you then fair enough but if you go
out looking for it it's like you're
deliberately looking for something to
hurt you yeah yeah you could literally
call it a form of self harm
no I think it's always I think it's oh
my gosh trauma is going to war not your
ex-boyfriend
oh my God how does that I understand
what you're trying to say I'm not
disagreeing I'm not agreeing but is that
how does that cause problems within
yourself when that is a video a problem
which you now just found what are you
well because at the end of the day if
you're if you go out looking for the
problem you talk about the likes on
Instagram the likes on Instagram I mean
to be honest like if you're not in a
relationship yeah even if you're in a
relationship I don't think it's a
problem if you like a girl's picture I
find it a problem when you start dming
them and trying to contact them and meet
up with them that is the issue but at
the end daylight if you if you don't
trust someone then you should genuinely
shouldn't be with them the whole
question is how did you find it
it's one thing it's like okay it's one
thing if a girl DMS you and and says oh
he screenshots whatever and it comes to
you but if you're going through his
likes all the time going through his
Instagram going through his DMS going
through his following yeah
if you're just doing one of the three
it's like you're looking for problems
but how is that looking for a problem
man the problem was already there okay
how but why would that problem
because you're not you're not you're not
going into a relationship in good faith
you know what good faith is yeah okay so
so because the question is why did you
look to begin with
there might have been something that
could trigger that okay but that there
might have been like for example you see
him like whenever you walk into the room
he quickly has his phone or that could
trigger your curiosity yeah right you
would want to know okay why is he hiding
his phone why is he doing that why is he
doing X Y and Z so that could be a valid
reason but then but why would you get
that
reason I guess sometimes why would you
get triggered by the fact he has his
phone is it not from it shows that he
doesn't feel comfortable no no that's
just him physically showing you that he
doesn't feel comfortable you seeing what
he's doing on his phone why should you
have to hide the phone from me if you
trust me
well how about if you put this turns his
phone flat I think you're getting low
but I think again sorry go ahead I think
again it links back to like insecurity
and trust issues and like maybe maybe
issues from past relationships yeah you
see what at the end of the day like
because if he's hiding us but I wouldn't
think I've never thought in this in my
life oh he's hiding us but I just think
oh he's just putting it away
it's the way it's not about him oh yeah
oh babe you're here I want to give you
attention but the the whole thing is
like it's like leave him or leave it
like yeah then leave him you don't have
to go through I guess some girls want
some um reassurance and there's nothing
wrong with that no there's nothing wrong
with reinsure something that you may
call problem doesn't mean it is a
problem
so at what cost like how often are you
going to go through his like it's
like are you gonna go through it and
then now you're happy you're never gonna
go through it yeah you're not happy
after going through it you'll con you'll
dig yourself a hole and you'll before
you know it you're probably checking
every day but so is this guy doing where
is he he's like
problem in your head some of the time
like you might even create an issue in
your head which doesn't even exist I
know I'm not overthinking right that's
crazy as that sounds crazy sounds some
people actually have to dig themselves a
problem
yeah no some people actually have to do
that yeah
they're in something toxic is that what
you mean yeah and some females just want
for the sake of argument just for
entertainment purposes to excitement
I love the difference yeah I've never
done that but obviously yeah
the booth like yeah and that's the
difference between most females because
not all females are the same no 100 yeah
but again like if you if you feel like
you have to check their socials every
day and like kind of checking what
they're doing
okay wait wait wait wait okay there's
nothing wrong with what there's nothing
wrong with checking with checking their
socials what do you mean by checking
yourself I love how she's sticking up
for me
I wait
because checking what by the way
going back to what she said like the
likes and who they're commenting at I'm
not talking about the DMS because I
can't actually log into these um
Instagram and see DMS but
the the comment is basically going up
turkey I was saying look good unless
that's their friend that's the whole
difference or unless that's someone that
they knew before okay question do you
want to be married someday
yeah do you think that's healthy for a
long-term marriage do you think that's
the future of success he shouldn't be
doing it if he's my own successful
marriages is to be looking through your
husband's following who he's liking on
Instagram all that
there's always something you can look
through yeah you know and sometimes you
take it out I mean some people meet the
husband's other family at the funeral
you know it just happened
sometimes you just take it out but
there's always going to be something to
look through yeah 100 and so it's not
necessarily that he should be liking the
photos it's like a mindset behind it
yeah
um okay I'm gonna Read Super chats for a
second okay as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
hello every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible